Так виглядає Європа в режимі суворого карантину.
Повсюди вживають безпрецедентних  для мирного часу заходів для боротьби з коронаврусом.
Це муніципальна поліція. Ми рекомендуємо уникати перебування надворі.
Ми стали свідками, як по всій Європі, та й по цілому світу, уряди вживають заходи,
які ще місяць тому були для багатьох із нас немислимі.
На тлі того, як у Європі запроваджують дедалі більше обмежень у повсякденному житті,
з'являютьсяпобоювання, що певні заходи можуть залишитися в силі
й після завершення пандемії.
Гадаю, важливе питання в тому, з чим ми залишимося, коли усе це закінчиться.
750 мільйонам мешканців Європи вже довелося пережити,
як в одну мить суворо обмежили їхнє право на свободу пересування.
Масштаби обмежень у різних країнах різні.
Так, у Швеції, наприклад, молодшим дітям все ще дозволяють ходити до школи.
Натомість у інших європейських країнах, зокрема, у Франції та Італії,
життя громадян майже цілкомпаралізовано.
А за порушення правил стягуються немалі штрафи:
в Італії мінімальний штраф встановлено у розмірі 400 євро.
Ті ж, хто мають підтверджений діагноз COVID-19,
за порушення карантину можуть опинитися у в'язниці.
Деякі заходи, яких вживають по всій Європі, менш помітні.
Приміром, оператори мобільного зв'язку в Італії, Німеччині та Австрії
діляться даними користувачів з органами системи охорони здоров'я,
допомагаючи контролювати, чи дотримуються люди заборони залишати оселю
та вимоги уникати зайвих контактів.
Дані анонімні, проте витік даних на веб-сайті міністерства охорони здоров'я Австрії
вже викликав занепокоєння щодо захисту особистих даних.
Європейські лідери запевняють: безпрецедентні обмеження - не назавжди.
Початковий період у 30 днів.
Щонайменше на 15 днів.
Після Великодня.
Одна європейська країна обрала дуже суперечливий шлях - це Угорщина.
Парламент країни схвалив законопроект про безстрокове продовження надзвичайного стану,
надавши націоналістично налаштованому прем'єрміністру Віктору Орбану
широкі повноваження.
Законопроект також передбачає ув'язнення як покарання для тих, хто поширює
"фейкові повідомлення" про коронавірус чи заходи проти нього.
Це підозріло. Чому вони не можуть сказати: гаразд,
наразі нам необхідно три місяці, а через три місяці ми можемо зібратися знову
і вирішити, чи варто подовжити.
Я думаю, що це був би доцільний, нормальний спосіб для вирішення такої ситуації.
Брюссель уже застеріг Угорщину, що та надто сильно порушує верховенство права.
Експерти стверджують, що, власне, встановленнятерміну дії тих чи інших заходів є визначальним,
коли йдеться про законність нових обмежень у Європі.
Важливо пам’ятати, що такі заходи, згідно з міжнародним правом щодо прав людини,
лише тоді є законними, якщо вони вважаються необхідними та якщо вони виправдані.
Також важливо, щоб вони були обмеженими в часі.
А ще - необхідний належний контроль,
демократична дискусія та моніторинг усіх цих заходів.
Деякі країни ЄС уже мають досвід, коли надзвичайні заходи
можуть тривати довше, ніж передбачалося.
Візьмімо, наприклад, Францію.
Після терактів у Парижі 2015 року уряд оголосив надзвичайний стан.
Неурядові організації критикували те, що виняткові повноваження
навіть перетворили на закон.
Низка європейських країн, серед яких Латвія, Грузія, Естонія, Вірменія та Румунія,
вже оголосили про намір відійти від Європейської конвенції про права людини
з огляду на пандемію коронавірусу.
Конвенція допускає втручання у громадянські свободи в період надзвичайного стану,
проте правозахисники вже закликають бути обережними.
Так, одна зі спецдоповідачів ООН написала у своєму мікроблозі:
Ми можемо пережити кризу в охороні здоров'я,
але якщо ми не повернемося до наших демократичних цінностей, ми програли війну.